I just found Jenna at the entrance to
the Microsoft press conference we're
here the e3
technically I'm going to not even Dave
lon so basically Dave zero excited Jenna
thought you writings got a couple things
of scared
oh okay quit any premium seats made
under the press conference and look who
I found
okay going to have nice curative what's
up okay
hi Darla green like everyone else I'm
the greens this is actually my natural
kid I wouldn't expect anything more from
you
[Applause]
and today we are the newest members of
the Xbox family fittingly named Xbox one
X promoted powerful console ever made
sets a new quality standard for gamers
new game creators starting on November
7th Xbox one X join the Xbox one and the
Xbox one hat when it launches normal
blood
we just got out of the xbox III
presentation where I keep wanting to
call it X of scorpions turtle I know
it's not
introduce yourself to might wonder what
Annette friend dear hi I'm Albert mellow
I run console marketing at Microsoft
this is the Xbox one x-x-x there were so
many DMX jokes people know yeah it was
great I'm unlucky a nice by the way
so just work with that out there X no
give it to you wait for you to get it on
your own text the never cursory I've had
I've had the old no power greater than X
logo on this Twitter feed for like a
year and I've just been waiting for this
moment that's yeah been there the whole
time
and here it is so you guys went through
so many different things today are the
high level things that everyone wants to
know of course hey I want to say it
starts with the games we had a great
games lineup we showed 42 games on our
stage the most diverse lineup 22 console
exclusives we should amazing true 4k
games like forth assassin's creed it was
an unbelievable lineup of games this is
the this is my baby this is the machine
that powers at all it is the world's
most powerful console 6 teraflops 12
gigabytes of gddr5 memory 326 gigabytes
per second memory bandwidth it is the
small I will use my Aladdin Jo unlimited
cosmic power itty-bitty living space we
have crammed a lot of performance into
the small sex we've ever built
yeah so it looks compatible and then we
show them the bathroom we came to do you
didn't mention much about the city yeah
we didn't get to talk about it in fact
you know it shares that beautiful family
resemblance with the Xbox one ass but in
the side it's completely different the
only component inside that's shared with
an Xbox one s is the blu-ray drive but
one of the things that we wanted to do
when I just talked about the care and
craftsmanship that we put in was on the
port arrangement and I know it sounds
silly but it's the level of detail that
we have with the team is that all the
ports are in the same place on Xbox one
is we even use the same power cable
which is a huge fight between the
marketing team and the engineering team
to make that happen but it means that if
you're upgrading from an Xbox one ass
I don't have to look I don't have to get
behind the TV exactly they're all saying
ports you can do if I feel that's
actually use right now because I'll tell
you how many times I mean I'm sure I'm
not the only one everyone's drunk like
okay is it and I have like what I will
do is I'll use the front-facing camera
on my phone and I start in behind my TV
I'm just like okay great
got it it's going to be the weirdest
feeling cuz it really if you literally
just go like that and it just works so
you can afraid really fiddle now I'm
deaf people compared to the Xbox one
edge I wish we had what to show you that
it is a little bit smaller it's two
pounds heavier then Xbox one as to when
you pick this thing up you're like oh my
god it is and there is so much tech that
we crammed in here and to do it with
this level of performance to keep the
elegant design to keep it cool and quiet
I think you've heard us talk about
things like the vapor chamber which you
normally see on the servers and high-end
PC graphics cards there's actually a guy
back at work bill hobus who had to
invent a power management system that
basically looks at every chip in the
console and the motherboard in total and
optimizes each xbox 1x
individually so that it's the most
efficient it can be so we don't waste
any power and it allows it thanks Bill
people's electric bills will be a little
bit smaller thanks to Bill Hovis and it
keeps all that performance in in the
smallest console we've ever built and
another thing as you guys mention which
is so exciting for people who have been
Xbox fans in the beginning we can now
play old-school Xbox original games so
there are unreal look I gotta say I was
sitting there in the crowd I've been
wanting to share this people for so long
there are guys on the team like myself
that have been around since we launched
the original console that wanted to see
this happen Phil's wanted to see it
happen your discs work you can you take
your discs they work
if you basically your digital
entitlement to work just like back and
Pat and you can actually system link all
three generations of consoles together
for land parties so you can get an OG
xbox 360 and an Xbox one that's right
you can actually do land parties with
your old discs on three generations of
consoles they know this but I skipped
out on one of my proms to go to a LAN
party all right but it was a PC LAN
party at the time so yeah is back into
that public awareness good night yes
what a fight made five dates I think you
guys did an incredible job at the press
conference in stage looked unbelievable
we were here in person and those screens
or unreal
I apologize at home if you did not get
to see the magnificence of the 4:3
screen we have there
[Music]
November $799 nothing in the world this
level of performance at that price and
get one quick like Mario yeah thank you
so much this is off of it now it's do
the little slow-mo montage this is the
new Xbox one X let me know comment below
and let me know what you guys think what
are you most looking forward to and what
old-school Xbox game are you most
looking forward to play backwards
compatibility for the way I'll see you
guys later
[Music]
getting a mug images